what's up blog is super-exciting
interview for me being a Jersey boy
growing up in the 90s hip-hop era Redman
the icon the legend comes through really
interesting conversation that I think
actually maps to a ton of executives who
pattex success kind of entrepreneurs
who've had success a ton of you who've
won in your profession with a little bit
of what do you do when being
contemporary could be slightly different
than what got you there and so I'm super
excited about this this this meeting I I
really think it's gonna bring a ton of
value to a lot of you so check it let me
know what you think I'm glad I'm
connected man absolutely thanks for all
the love man that means a lot to me
coming from you like I'm 42 and from
Jersey so like I got real love for you
man I really like especially when you
hit me up the other day like like to be
real quick like I'm so I'm always foot
boy noses you know this I'm always
focused on how I can bring value it's
just my default because I think that's
where the leverage is especially because
if I never have to cash in those chips
then I'm a legend right but there was
just something about our exchange the
other day which is why I wanted to get
this in real quick like just want to get
to know you guys but most importantly
and are you'll be able to help boy you
maybe you'll be able to help but like
I'm super intrigued on how I can help I
want to know what the [ __ ] you're up to
what's going on like how you're thinking
about [ __ ] but I'm I'm interested I'll
help okay okay is the character he's the
guy who has to be chasing that attention
and getting to the new spots before
every 100% such a brain
and such a personality such a
personality he was made for culture and
whenever the spotlights on 1997 MTV BT
then it's gonna work and when the
spotlights not on it won't because if
you don't like but anytime people know
like seal it will work every time like
talent and charisma and magic isn't
teachable the only time magic and
charisma and talent aren't winning is
when there's not distribution behind it
the N that's why what I'm up to is so
powerful once I finished building this
machine I'm building a Death Star
literally the Death Star of
communication and then you just point it
and when I say can help I'm interested
in helping to point it at you cuz it
will but when I say this it could take
14 months but it's like as long as you
do the push-ups and shrink the raw egg
you'll win that fight it's about staying
discipline that's all you know and then
what else and you like this it just
reverse-engineering you I think you know
people of our generation like it's not
like people their generation we're like
it's just so it's like part of their
body you know like I have a lot of
empathy for people that especially if
you were a celebrity before it all those
rules are broken it's the reverse and so
it's about it's about creating an
infrastructure that allows you to
produce the amount of content you need
to produce like what like let's talk
about it like family like what the [ __ ]
do you want to happen and how much of it
is art and and happiness how much is
financial to me when you're figuring out
the next thing you just break it down to
cut like just unemotional columns right
there's money and then there's like
creative happiness those are two buckets
and then and then you just kind of like
roll like like which one needs to be
scratched
oh by the way always both when it's best
right and then just getting to know you
like right like is that around fashion
is that around music is that around you
know funny clips I mean you could you
have a lot of flexibility
- no the doctor also owns a clothing
store somewhere I'm aware I'm away I
don't think that we've spoken a lot
about how we can leverage his brand and
how we leverage so what would you like
to happen right um first I would like to
take advantage of my platform that I
have yeah I'll be a red man my brand I
think through the years that my manager
and me a myth as well we kept our brand
up to a level that we're Hollies from
real and it's not tainted with a lot of
BS so now I wanna take advantage of that
cash in some of those chips yeah
absolutely all these media platforms
make sure that um you know generating
and right funds and and getting what's
worth being on a social media and then
exploiting my uh my creativity you know
far as cliffs movies if so much is what
do you think man what do you think
musically cuz I don't need to know I
don't even hear it I don't need to hear
that any of that from you I'm just
razzing you but like just your
perspective on like you know like and
you know like we like keeping it real
but like what's your curiosity of it
like how do you think and actually
before I apologize where are you with
music like mentally Oh
mentally I'm a hundred percent meaning
you want to produce projects absolutely
where are you contractually you're free
agent you got the obligations what's the
last thing you did the last time I put
out was on in groups distribution in
California mr. test in the air and I'm
doing a new album muddy waters too and
I'm putting that out door and goo
distribution if we start if this started
like a real relationship that we were
really like helping you pro but like
just help you like family stuff would
you wait can you wait yes because I want
you but I'm thinking about it's the best
feel isn't it okay what do you think for
real
this is the like to like make this a
real meeting this is the right time for
everybody to be here real truthful
because I really have a lot of intent to
help I'm so [ __ ] busy
like I don't want it like I want to deal
in straight truths because then I know
what to do if I start feeling like I'm
trying to figure out exactly what then
I'm dead because I'm just too you see
what I mean and what I mean by that is
like do you really want to do this what
do you really want to do where is it you
know like I'm curious like for example
you're such a real [ __ ] legend back
to how this [ __ ] all works out there's a
ton of 17 19 year olds that are really
meaningful in the music game who don't
know who you are because that just held
what life works you know we all know
that but if you actually decide to like
like what I don't have a sense of
because I don't know that's why I'm
asking then I'll get back to you I
apologize is where your line is between
you wanting Muddy Waters to to be really
successful and what are the lines in the
sand artistically that can't be crossed
to make it successful and the cool part
with me is I don't care I just want to
know let me explain I think you should
have 5 to 6 meaningful collaborations on
that album and siphon the pulse of
what's emerging but you might say I
don't want to [ __ ] with lil zan like I'm
not putting 21 savage on this like I
don't know that but once I understand it
and understand where I'm not gonna make
you move your lines I just want to know
what the lines are and then I want to
fill it with the [ __ ] that I know
creates magic you understand red you can
make some music doc the music they like
they have like not the music that people
expect nothing like only Goods gonna
happen
Lil Wayne made a [ __ ] rock album
he's okay
like if the first thing you do is a
[ __ ] piece-of-shit song straight up
by the market you wouldn't put it out if
you don't think it was good but let's
say it doesn't work it's gonna do
nothing to your [ __ ] status Michael
Jordan played for the Wizards but my
intuition is you do it four times 17
year olds in Oklahoma City to me like yo
my new favorite artist is Redman that's
what I think I know with like every
ounce of my soul and you do that and let
me give you a little secret the
skateboard shop a clothing brand the
following count on Instagram it all
starts changing Khaled and snapchat is a
once in a decade thing you putting out a
song that gets hot
that's a foregone conclusion you just
need to get the [ __ ] out of the jail
that everybody put you in and you and
guess what they love you and you love
them that's right but guess what I got
[ __ ] on for not being the wine guy
anymore when I started talking about
business until I did it
maybe two cents below make sure you
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
what's your thoughts on red man what's
your thoughts on my performance in this
in this meeting
[Music]
[Music]